suddenly like when things aren't like
really gonna work out or whatever or
like you know you're broken up there's
this there's I just need to be the
hottest guy in the world feeling yeah
dude you know the crying between sets
[Music]
welcome to another great episode of
careful boys we have with us nimish
Patel nimish Patel and we also got a pat
over there which is really great also
Pat which is really great
thanks [ __ ] I was trying to Hype it
up but no one else well it sounds
sarcastic when he says it no it's just
trying to repeat your exact words man
busting a can over here saying the same
thing the last guy said I wanted to know
what
what's the most unhealthiest you have
ever been
well you're asking everybody either
physical mental anything if you can
think back to your life and pinpoint
when you were at your most unhealthiest
what was going on
I was eating hot Cheetos all day are you
serious that's your [ __ ] answer no
that is so mad sir I can't get the [ __ ]
out of here
it's like I don't know I've always been
healthy you know no I think about early
20s when I had started comedy I wasn't
really cognizant of how how late I was
eating and what I was eating and when I
was eating it and [ __ ] I was just
beating like
mac and cheese and fries at like 11 12 1
o'clock in the morning that was now look
back at those pictures of me I'm like
God damn what the [ __ ] was I on eating
that [ __ ] were you actually like fatter
yes 100 I was not healthy at all and
those come
add that with the fact that I could
drink like [ __ ] fish like I would be
drinking all the time you know we hang
out late we just drink and you don't
realize the toll is taken on your body
that was definitely unhealthy I was
[ __ ] and then and what did it take
for you to like Turn Around from that
see myself in a photo but like God damn
that'll do it too yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is wrong with me bro like I don't
that's not supposed to be
I'm people say I'm skinny but I don't
feel it and I don't look it you know
what I mean like now I got changed then
also learning about family history of
having like heart disease I'm like yeah
I gotta change my [ __ ] that'll do it
real fast that's a big thing too yeah
what about you
because you've had some it sounds like
throughout time you've had some
interesting like struggles with it
sometimes sure were you a fat kid no I
was always like this small skinny skinny
fat kid that was like my deal and I
still kind of am
um but for the most part like a lot of
it was when I started weight cutting a
bunch for like competitions
I was just being super unhealthy because
like we didn't know how to do it the
right way and we would like
I remember one of the fights that I had
I tried to cut like 16 pounds and like
a week and a half yeah and then and then
they tell me oh yeah you're gonna be
fighting in a lower weight the guy can't
make way a blah blah and I would like
lose another five pounds and I just
ended up restricting myself so much that
like I was just obsessed over food I
would like write down dude I had like a
it was it was pretty bad like I would
like uh write down all the foods that I
was gonna eat
and just obsess over it think about it
all the time watch like like food porn
stuff you know and then just obsess
about it all the time and then once I
could eat I would just binge like crazy
and then I put on like I just kept
getting heavier and heavier my gut kept
getting bigger and bigger and like I was
like kind of in shape but then it got
harder for me to make weight constantly
and I would just always go through this
process of trying to make weight and
just [ __ ] myself over get myself really
sick and just not do it right and I
would perform like [ __ ] every time and I
just would keep doing that and then to
the point where I just kind of really
gotten healthy with uh my food that I
consumed and then I had to really sit
back and really figure out how to like
eat properly how to be and I was like
and I was like a fitness trainer too so
well you were trainer throughout this
time yeah I was like coaching people all
the time you hypocrite not nutrition but
just like personal training you know got
it
um I was like damn dude I gotta [ __ ]
clean up my act and then that was pretty
much
I was probably like
mid-20s ish you know so you told
yourself like nobody ever went hey man
you look like you you're letting go a
little bit not really because I think I
hit it well you know I think I hit it
well but it was I knew what I was doing
at like night I was like binge eating
like crazy it just wasn't it just wasn't
healthy at all and I just felt like [ __ ]
all the time but my poops are great did
you feel like the times you were most
physically unhealthy it kind of
coincided with your mental health at the
same time too or is it like two
different things if I was cognizant of
my mental health probably I would yeah
probably I probably wasn't in the best
like heads uh like mindset wise and like
looking back retrospect yeah I probably
wasn't thinking about the right things I
was just kind of
I was like unorganized doing everything
last minute anyway so I just kind of
[ __ ] myself over so yeah I guess in a
way it's like because you're like
there's that Obsession too because I
feel like that's mentally unhealthy to
be so super obsessive over any one thing
right yeah for sure at least to the
point of like
how it started for me so because I was
obsessing over food all the time and
then I was actively
like it was affecting my day-to-day like
dude I remember in college every time
God would always like fall asleep when I
would drive home for my commute at like
Northridge I would get really sleepy and
I think the only way I could stay up was
your boy is going to McDonald's you know
every day and I was going to school
Monday through Friday so like every day
I was like eating something at
McDonald's at McDonald's or some of the
fast food and I was eating on the way
because as soon as I finished class
um I would drive back and then start
working right away because then you
developed you developed ritual too yeah
and it's habit right and it's it's tied
with my day-to-day everyday routine and
then that's how people get [ __ ] over
they don't even realize and that was my
thing I didn't even realize like what I
was doing was
like bad because you talk yourself into
these weird pockets of you rationalize
it oh I'm gonna fall asleep so I need to
eat something well what like you do that
[ __ ] to yourself all the time and then
[ __ ] fast forward to you looking like
[ __ ] and then that affects your business
too especially in the field that I'm in
so so what what is it now that you that
keeps you from relapsing like how do you
like keep yourself in check today well
for me it's just you know the one
dealing with clients that have to deal
with this all the time and just kind of
helping them navigate through that stuff
and also too it's like if you want to if
you want to help people with the stuff
you got to be about it you know that's
probably the biggest yeah that's one
that's one of my motivations but also
too it's like the knowledge of where I
was before to where I am now was very
different so I understand it on a
different level and I understand that
like yeah obviously you don't want to
restrict yourself too much but you you
want to have some structure from your
day to day you can't just be eating like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and dude if there's
one thing I'm really good at it's me
knowing how to eat like an [ __ ] like
I I'm a bottomless pit dude I could I
could stuff myself pretty crazy yeah and
you love food oh dude I love it
specifically watermelon
that's a good choice at least it's kind
of healthy hey we never got into how the
[ __ ] you lost weight because you were
fat as [ __ ] for years you were fat as
[ __ ]
it's a good intro Ryan yeah yeah I
didn't even know this but you were a
little fat you were a little fatty one
time I didn't know it either when I met
him and he was in college he was like
super skinny so I was like oh dude well
dude one time David came in here and was
like I remember you when you were fat
and he just yelled at Anthony and we
were like yo you're fat because you grew
up a fat kid right I was I was tubby you
know I was a little bit uh chunky I had
nice IQ roles I have a very Infamous
photo of my sister holding me up as like
an infant and you know like the [ __ ]
Michelin tire guy like the roles were
just three-dimensional you know it was
like 4D like [ __ ] Universal Studio
stuff
um and then I got really chubby as a
young one somewhere I hit puberty I
stretch out got like scrawny skin like
not cool skinny like uh like uh could
look like you could break me in the wind
skinny type oh so that was just
metabolism and growth spurt yeah I had
no control I had no discipline I had no
[ __ ] nothing you know and then I get
into uh this this ties more so with the
unhealthy part I got into like the sales
job after college this is like before I
started dancing uh as a choice and as a
career
and uh in this sales job I would
constantly have to like drive around the
city and stuff like that all the time
right so I was like always just on the
road and so I got into a routine like
you said I got into this routine where I
stopped by the gas station in the
morning I get myself [ __ ] monster a
beef Slim Jim and crumb or powdered
Donuts
like every day how's life work and then
like you know
why are you laughing it's just such a
funny breakfast
that's a gas station breakfast yeah it
is it is and then you don't want to
spend a lot of money for lunch so you
just get something like tacos two tacos
that [ __ ] El Pollo Loco was my jam or
I mean Jack in the Box
um and then uh you know at night and
stuff like that you'd be like stressed
out so I like hit this like Z bong this
giant bong and then you just eat
whatever the [ __ ] was affordable but
like dank damn volume you're looking for
volume yeah and then you go to sleep and
you wake up and you go back to the gas
station next day and I was doing this
like every day like I'm talking like six
days a week type [ __ ] damn so I hit I
hit like 203 pounds [ __ ] with like but
when you're coming from like super
skinny scrawny like you could break me
like a twig and you get to like 200 plus
pounds that's not muscle weight that's
like
just like like a water bed yeah you know
you could push me and I'll still be like
waving for like a day
um and then I got these like these body
abscesses almost like pimples oh [ __ ]
that would show up like right here on
the side and it would be really annoying
it's all that Monster energy bubbling up
yeah
you have immunodeficiency I'm like I
don't even know how to spell that yeah
I'm like what do you do they're like
what do you do or you know like what can
you do for they're like ah we don't
really know because it's like a
deficiency but you know it turned into a
part of my lifestyle where I started I
showered twice a day I had to sleep
eight hours I cut out weed I cut out
alcohol for like eight to like nine
months and I literally didn't do any of
that stuff because I thought that I had
this like skin problem
um but then because I had to go into
that because I had this problem and I
cut that stuff out eventually it got me
into like a the momentum of just like
maybe I need to like cut some other
stuff out maybe I should like you know
start working out
um I don't want to like give too much
credit to the fact that I was like kind
of heartbroken which is like what every
guy's real diet is right yeah they get
all jacked and [ __ ] yeah so it's the
best go to the gym I had this like thing
where um these like weight uh these uh
cut and weight people [ __ ] previous
wrestlers would say oh if you don't like
running what should you do you walk
uphill on a treadmill right can you
explain how that works real quick 12 30
kind of thing that that new trend oh
well I think that's just something that
like a lot of bodybuilders do just for a
long volume of time where
you're not necessarily exerting yourself
because especially when you're heavier
and you never run and you gained a bunch
of weight like new weight and then you
start running your joints gonna be
[ __ ] in pain right so a lot of times
you can do something longer period of
time at a lower intensity and you can
get your heart rate
up at a moderate amount where you're
still like okay I'm burning calories and
after you do that for like 30 40 minutes
you could burn like a good amount of
calories over time yeah because I
couldn't run I hated running I couldn't
run two miles for [ __ ] like 10
minutes but I could walk uphill for 30
and then I found this meal called the
skinless chicken breast Meal
which was like a skinless chicken breast
like neon [ __ ] vegetables uh and then
it was like maybe 270 calories for like
five bucks filled you up I eat that
twice a day let's go and I'll hit the
gym twice a day and then I went down
from 280 to I mean from uh 203 to like
165.
wow that's how long did it take to get
from 203 it took me like three months
dude that's fast as [ __ ]
but like think about it you're eating
what you said two meals 270 yeah so dude
you're like not even you're barely
eating I think it was lightweight
anorexia yeah that's probably not the
healthiest way to do it but hey you got
yourself damn
got skinnier that's for sure how much do
you weigh right now right now like 175
180 and you're tall you're like six feet
yeah yeah that's healthy right yeah same
stuff bro when Anthony Texas a [ __ ]
shirt off and he goes for a walk this
guy's kind of jacked you [ __ ] yoked
man you're kind of Jack you're ripped
I'm clearly the buffest guy here you
know I'm on the opposite Journey right
now I'm trying to go up and wait like at
least like five or ten more pounds did
you always have trouble gaining weight
yeah your metabolism was like super fast
Huh Cheetos ain't gonna help you
it's the opposite where I feel like my
unhealthiest was when I was the
skinniest when I was like 110 like that
was like the dude like 110. yeah it's
because one you're gonna float away uh
because I work on my computer I'm not
really physically active and the only
time I'm physically active is if I'm
dancing but you don't eat probably a lot
huh exactly I don't eat a lot because I
always feel like I never need to because
I'm not even using up the energy anyway
that's crazy yeah but so that but that
kept happening I would say this was like
actually pretty recent like maybe three
four years ago and I was like you're a
buck ten three years ago how much do you
think he weighs right now
12. no not 20. I'm still actually I'm
like 120 right now oh my god dude it's a
professional though yeah yeah I'm like
120. I pick them up every now and then
though
a part of it was because I was also
really um
I was in the habit of like smoking weed
all the time uh going out to drink some
but that didn't make you fat no because
I don't get the munchies I don't get the
munchies the [ __ ] is wrong with it and
then I was on my computer barely
physically active so I didn't I never
wanted to eat that much but then this
past couple of years I've been like okay
I need to try to change something about
that because I feel like I have less
energy when I weigh less yeah sure yeah
I do well you've been lifting more too
right you've been you've been lifting
more yeah I've been going to the gym
more uh I've been break dancing now so
that helps a lot because I feel like I'm
way stronger now than before and it also
in turn like make makes me want to eat
more too oh okay so your appetite goes
on exactly yeah yeah you have a Target
weight that you want to reach at least
135 like I want to get to 135 so like 15
pounds you can do it for sure but I
don't like the way where like people are
like oh you just gotta eat a lot of
calories because for me that's what they
just said no but you kind of do though
you kind of have no because it [ __ ] up
my my digestion so how how many meals do
you have a day 3 are they are they
pretty spaced out yeah they're pretty
spaced out then it's going to be an
adjustment period yeah because I don't
want to just have one to two meals like
regularly yeah that was very clear
because I was just like I didn't feel
hungry or it was just that's just how
it's just your body huh yeah yeah
because I always tried to feel it out
and you must have been saving a lot of
money I know dude you probably spent way
less than the average dude for sure but
um it was also what I was eating too
wasn't that healthy because like I was
conscious of it but not really what were
you eating just like Asian food like
[ __ ] healthy yeah like just uh protein
also a lot of sodiums and [ __ ] yeah yeah
like not enough veggies not enough
fruits like now I do that I try to
incorporate fruit and veggies like way
more but but when you're trying to gain
weight like volume is the game yeah but
I'm not also in a hurry either so like
this past year I gained like five pounds
and it just stayed there and I never
went oh nice okay so I want to keep
gaining like weight but consistent but
in that same yeah yeah yeah I don't want
to be like three months transformation
you know I don't yeah how do you feel
about Mass Gators are mass gainers
unhealthy I don't I think they're fine
yeah so why don't you try maybe like a
mask I did I did what's a mass gainer
It's Like A protein that has like a gang
of calories like a gang of protein it
like it's [ __ ] packed with like ice
cream because I have a fast metabolism
too and my thing is like I would work
out and I would just like kind of lose
weight as well and then I started taking
a mask Gator and then I noticed like oh
I can gain some weight honestly gaining
weight is usually way harder for most
people than it is to lose weight like
it's just it's it's tough because you
kind of have to be the same way you are
a little uncomfortable when you're
dieting and you're like a little hungry
all the time it's kind of the opposite
way of you being like a little full
yeah a lot of the time you feel like
you're forcing yourself to eat to the
point where you're like [ __ ] I'm gonna
throw up yeah you kind of have to have
that little bit of discomfort like
eventually you get you'll adjust to it
but like also you got to make sure
you're lifting doing all that stuff
especially if you want to build muscle
but like as far as like
for most people like people that are
like hard gainers or people that have
like fast metabolisms it is hard to be
consistently eating enough protein and
enough calories every day because
sometimes the numbers are like crazy
like there's no way I could eat 3 000
calories in a day and do that seven days
out the week for a [ __ ] you know it's
expensive time yeah it's expensive it
takes a lot of time cooking so much time
dude do you feel like when you're at
your lightest that also coincided with
some sort of space mentally for you yeah
actually uh I feel like I was pretty
content with everything because at the
time uh I was with
um I was in a relationship I was living
in a house where like everything was
kind of the same and so I never felt the
need to like really progress you know
but then after a lot of things change
you know break up move back here you
know whatever I was just like dude
Something's Gotta Go like and it just
started making me like push more to like
why okay if I'm only gonna be here like
on this Earth for this long like this
try to look as best as I can feel as
best as I can whatever and just push it
you know but then yeah I ultimately it
just put me in a more positive uh
habitat you know hey breakups are still
the best you know
I remember just like the discipline the
juju to like just get ready like maybe
it's also coming off of the dynamic of
being in like a long-term relationship
where you start getting really
comfortable you know what I mean yeah
you're just a piece of [ __ ] and then
suddenly like when things aren't like
really gonna work out or whatever or
like you know you're broken up there's
this there's this I just need to be the
hottest guy in the world feeling yeah
dude you know the crying between sets
I think the biggest thing mentally was
uh when you're content or whatever
you're really unaware of a lot of things
around you and so for me mentally I
don't think I was at a good place
because now I'm way more like aware of
certain things and so my brain feels
like it's actually doing work and being
present you know that's true yeah and
like like Nina said it takes just one
candid photo to be like who the [ __ ] is
that
for real my motivation right now is the
bet I got going on with a friend of mine
was like I gotta have a six-pack and a
six months from now oh bro you're right
there dude six-pack shortcuts six pack
shortcuts yeah yeah what's the bet
though like a thousand bucks a thousand
dollars wait are you betting with Kumail
no no
one of you who gets a six-pack first or
who has a is if either if if he has a
six-pack and I don't I owe him two G's
I have a six-pack and he doesn't he owes
me a grand what if both of us have a
six-pack then no one knows anyone
anything and if neither one of us have a
six-pack then neither one of us owes
anyone anything why do you have the
short end of the state I think it's
because I'm starting at a a better spot
than he is so like he's he's in the you
guys are adjusting for the odds yeah so
what's your routine what are you doing
uh for right now I'm on the calorie
cutting portion of it uh and then I'll
I'm already kind of looking lean right
yeah yeah see the striations yeah yeah
so then at some point I'll start working
out a lot heavier but right now it's
just like because I also
when I work out heavy I've been injured
twice working on heavy and I had to like
I had a hernia I was like no that was
like that was a few years ago but I was
working out I was going the Oscar so I'm
getting [ __ ] shape bro and then like
that Row the back row I remembered
specifically that night when I did this
back exercise that night I went home and
my balls hurt I was like oh I did
something something's [ __ ] up okay
that's crazy when you're back doing back
exercising your balls hurt yeah yeah
a [ __ ] uh uh row machine but not like
uh not the actual row but it's like the
chest press it's also a real thing you
could adjust the machine okay I was
doing that I was like huh that's weird
my balls hurt but then it didn't it
didn't die
yeah yeah yeah I don't I have a pump in
my balls my testicle is getting so
strong
and then like at that night I was taking
a [ __ ] and it was just like oh that's
not supposed to hurt like that oh [ __ ]
because hernia pain is just like random
extremely sharp pain in your balls yeah
and then next morning I woke up I was
like a [ __ ] doctor at City MD was
like oh you just have a Barney I'm like
[ __ ] and they're like you gotta have
surgery for that did you end up having
to get surgery yeah I got surgery they
put a little you know
um a mesh uh thing in over where the
hernia mesh yeah she's stupid
wait so our hernia is like where are
they located typically they're growing
the groin like in front of like right
above your oh so it's in the abdominal
area exactly and not in the bathroom
it's your part of your intestine coming
out of a hole in your abdominal cavity
and it could be really bad or it could
be manageable some a lot of most
people's hernias are manageable
um and you don't have to have surgery or
they could just wear like a strap or
something and then like a belt yeah you
can have a belt but like the recommended
procedure is surgery uh it's just like a
mesh plate over I know a guy who has a
hernia and he's like he's like I'll just
push it back in yeah yeah
that's what I just go about my day it's
like that's like Audi so it's like
muscle and it just pops through the
muscle is that what it is yeah I don't
know what the where the what the
abdominal cavity itself is but
there's like a hole in it and your
intestines will come out of it you can
just push it back in
yeah it's [ __ ] up the thought of that
but the I don't know how they test it
through the to find it they they grab
your balls and they like they poke
inside and I guess like they can feel
part of it for tubing out and it's like
that's that's what causes the pain in
the balls damn so you got to search in
there every now and then you know you
can do your own hernia check yeah yeah
how do you check Pat did you ever have a
did you ever have a period where you
thought you were unhealthy I was like oh
almost always well I was just skinny I
was always like like really skinny I
have a fast metabolism too blessed with
a big dick too I'm sure yeah I just Tiny
Dick I have a super small dick
um [ __ ] you dude but I I just would the
same thing like just drinking too much
never like to the
like when I was younger I used to drink
soda like a [ __ ] bro like I
remember like I would how many a day
like four a day and like I was like all
running around at the park and then I
come home and just like instead of water
just grab a Coca-Cola and just pound
that [ __ ] and I did that for years we
didn't know we're kids you know but
still like you're Invincible yeah it's
true still like God damn that can't be
good you know and and just periods of my
life where like I was just drinking out
of hand like skinny and just drinking
and drinking I was like all right I
gotta chill the [ __ ] out like I'm
drinking literally for like three weeks
straight but you never had any like
health problems from that never I mean
not like any serious health problems I
used to have bad acne though like really
bad acne oh yeah and then I went to a
doctor and he I didn't want to take
pills and he was like just stop eating
meat for a while and then I was like he
told me to go vegan but I didn't go
vegan I just went vegetarian for like 10
months and my acne went away like that
yeah and then it stayed away is that is
that a source for acting for a lot of
people me I don't know I don't know
maybe not meat but the hormones inside
the meat yeah I mean I told the story
last time I was here but maybe I didn't
but last in April or whatever I went I
went to the next game the the game that
they lost to the Celtics and they had a
uh David Chang sandwich restaurant in at
Barclays Center it's a spicy chicken
sandwich I ate that [ __ ] and uh so spicy
but delicious that night my wife had
made like a Halal chicken and rice like
that's what I I wanted it because I just
come off a tour something like let's
make that and I ate that too even though
I had the spicy chicken sandwich
that night I went to the my two days
later like I had mad stomach pain I just
thought I'd just there's uh eating too
much indigestion or whatever
and then
um I thought I had uh uh what's it
called some kind of food poisoning so I
was just doing what they do Bart which
is like bananas applesauce rice and
toast which we were supposed to eat yeah
it encourages the yeah yeah it just
helps like it prevents diarrhea because
I have the coalescence you know big old
fiber turns out turns out
I had a bowel obstruction which is when
your bowel was inflamed and it gets
attached to like something in your body
cavity which is like unknown but it gets
attached to that so all the [ __ ] I was
doing all the fiber I was putting in was
actually making it worse I said like
crazy pain go to the hospital they put
like this they oh you have bowel
obstruction they put a tube through your
nose into your stomach it's called the
NG tube a nasogastric tube it's the
worst thing I ever like my mood for
those 12 hours that it was in was like
was I was the grumpiest [ __ ] there
was it's terrible the incident came out
I was like like my mood like immediately
changed I was like nice to the doctors
all this [ __ ] but when that [ __ ] was in
my nose because you feel it you can't
not feel it it's in your throat and they
can't go through your mouth because your
gag reflex will act up so they have to
go through your nose and then put it
into your and they pump they're just
pumping [ __ ] it's literally like [ __ ]
out of your [ __ ] through your oh
through your nasal so you're literally
seeing you should come out through your
it's like bile and [ __ ] and like air
because it's all just built up in there
actual [ __ ] yeah like it's brown I don't
know if it's a physical because I don't
know if it's been fully digested but
it's like it's at this part in your
[ __ ] oh it's still early [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's early [ __ ] it's not your lower
[ __ ]
yeah yeah and they're just doing it so
it it it like decompresses your
abdominal cavity in your intestines so
that you can actually like you're saying
you're moving you can move [ __ ]
science so for like four days after that
[ __ ] was done I couldn't eat anything
like I had to liquid diet only just
water clear liquids only for the first
three days it also sounds like a good
diet plan tomato soup I'm bringing all
that to say like
my skin cleared up like I have like a
look [ __ ] Flawless everyone's like
you're glowing man
I'm gonna get balance actions every now
and then
yeah
and G tube at home like it's like do it
yourself like [ __ ] like Diet is so much
of your skin it impacts so much of
everything you're doing but like my skin
clear everything was glowing I felt hurt
like I felt and normally if I'm that
made me want to fast like like once a
week I didn't but then maybe like I was
like I shouldn't I should cleanse myself
maybe you want to think about that idea
yeah it's like oh this is a good I can
see the value of it and that because I
knew I couldn't eat like I was never
craving it I wasn't like I gotta eat oh
you you weren't fighting discipline you
were just like I don't want to die
exactly I was like I don't want this
[ __ ] to happen again but by that third
or fourth day I was just
I was dreaming of tomato soup like
anything I could eat I was just it's the
only thing I thought about for like that
fourth day I remember I hit a point
where I was like I need something right
now and that that I think the fourth day
is when they say you could start eating
like a little bit like I was melting
saltine crackers in my [ __ ] tomato
soup that's a luxury at a certain point
yeah yeah and it was the most the first
sip of tomato soup I had after not only
having water was the it was Campbell's
and it was the greatest tomato soup I
ever had it's all perspective it was so
yeah
imagine one spoon just acne
but like the skin thing is well it
really hit me because I was like my like
moderate acne went like I have like acne
you can't see necessarily but my pores
cleared up all the [ __ ] yeah it's like
God damn it's just all food
[Music]
foreign